داخل اروقه البيت الابيض تجرى محادثات في
سباق مع الزمن وان قيل ان اصدارها ايجابيا
لكن ان فشلت في الوصول الى اتفاق ستعم
الفوضى ليس الاقتصاد الامريكي وحسب بل
العالم ايضا
فنزاع بين الحزبين الامريكيين على مساله
رفع سقف الدين عن حده الاقصى البالغ واحدا
وثلاثين تريليونا و400 مليار دولار قد
يؤدي للتخلف واشنطن عن سداد ديونها امر
يعني ان الحكومه لن تستطيع اقتراض المال
ودفع فواتيرها ويهدد بفوضى في الاقتصاد
العالمي وتدهور اسعار ومعدلات الرهن
العقاري العالميه
وزيره الخزانه كانت
حذرت الكونغرس بانه من المحتمل ان تنفذ
اموال الولايات المتحده وتتخلف عن سداد
فواتيرها في وقت مبكر من اول يونيو وبدون
رفع سقف الدين فان معاناه الاسر الامريكيه
ستكون شديده بيضا قال ان التخلف عن السداد
غير مطروح ووصف محادثاته مع رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مقاثي بانها بناء الاخير قال
انه يعتقد انه بالامكان التوصل لاتفاق ما
يعارض رفع سقف الدين يطالب الجمهوريون
بخفض في الميزانيه يزيد على اربعه
دولار امر سيؤدي الى الغاء العديد من
الاولويات التشريعيه لبايدن بينما يرفض
الديمقراطيون الخطوه ويعرضون بدلا من ذلك
الاستمرار في الانفاق دون تغيير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات وتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات